alerte rose alerte rose c'est chaud
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Thierry Ardisson
j'ai décidé de poser aux gens les
questions que je posais au cela
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer faire l'amour pour aimer pour
faire l'amour faire l'amour pour faire
l'amour
quel est pour vous le lieu idéal pour
faire l'amour alors les Italiens c'est
la machine à laver parce que ça vibre
vous c'est quoi un peu partout le salon
la chambre le lit en classique pour la
cuisine la salle de bain un bon vieux
lit 140 par 190 la voiture il y a pas de
vieux idéal tous les lieux sont idéaux
l'ascenseur quel est l'endroit où vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour je
pense qu'un cimetière ça pourrait me
bloquer et dire dans une mosquée je
pense en public dans le lit de ma
grand-mère est-ce que vous préférez une
femme qui fait bien l'amour mais qui est
moche ou une femme qui fait mal l'amour
mais qui est très jolie ah c'est une
bonne question un homme qui fait violer
je fais pas de moche et pas de moche
tout le monde est beau
est-ce que vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer je panique je drague donc
je pense me faire draguer les deux à me
faire marier me faire draguer je
préférais embrasser ou faire embrasser
une différence pour faire embrasser de
faire embrasser c'est moi qui embrasse
préférez larguer ou vous faire larguer
je crois que
me faire larguer je trouve ça beaucoup
moins dur est-ce que vous préférez être
caressé par quelqu'un qui vous répugne
ou battu par quelqu'un qui vous aime
[Musique]
un caressé par quelqu'un qui m'aurait pu
par quelqu'un qui m'aime quelqu'un qui
nous aime qui nous bas et il y a un
problème quelque part bah tu pour
quelqu'un qui vous aime on se bat
toujours avec les gens quand même est-ce
que vous pensez que l'amour est
compatible avec le mariage oui oui je
pense
payer pour faire l'amour vous faire
payer pour faire l'amour
me faire payer
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
rapports sexuels avec une personne que
vous avez rencontré le jour même oui non
et c'est même mieux deux fois est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des rapports sexuels
dans un lieu public oui oui
plusieurs fois on s'adapte tout mon
village d'enfance toutes les petites
rues genre un parc c'était sympa au bord
de lac jamais est-ce que vous avez des
préservatifs dans votre sac là non c'est
pas de sac mais dans mon sac ouais
je devrais est-ce que vous observer un
fantasme inavouable et jamais réalisé
ouais il y en a plein je suis pas obligé
de le dire
faire ça avec plusieurs femmes je sais
pas encore essayé j'ai fait deux mais on
part sur 3 5
nu sur la route 66 aux États-Unis
[Musique]